dave ramsey is finding himself in front
of the cancellation
firing squad for his comments on student
loan forgiveness and
and also the stimulus and he was
trending yesterday
because people were very upset about
this and let's take a listen to his
offensive remarks and will decide if
they really are all that offensive
this is a political gimme by
progressives simply trying to buy votes
and we know that because when you go
from ten thousand in forgiveness to
fifty thousand in forgiveness
the people who benefit are not lower
income people the vast majority of
people that have an average income or
less
have less than ten thousand dollars in
student loan debt the vast majority of
people who would be blessed by moving it
from ten to fifty
are high income earners so again this is
all political rhetoric it's not reality
you come from an interesting perspective
you talk to americans across the country
every day on your radio program
what what do you believe is the right
number or the right answer for a
for the next stimulus check well
i don't believe in a stimulus check
because if six hundred dollars or
fourteen hundred dollars changes your
life
you were pretty much screwed already you
got other issues going on
uh you have a you have a career problem
you have a debt problem you have a
relationship problem you have a
mental health problem something else is
going on if 600 dollars changes your
life
and that's not talking down to folks
i've been bankrupt i've been broke and i
work with people every day who are
hurting i love people i want people to
be lifted up
but this is again it is it is just
political rhetoric and it's just
throwing dollars out there it's peeing
on a forest fire
okay so that's what people were crying
about which first of all agree or
disagree just the crying about it give
me a break
uh your you're dog you're talking down
you're you're being
just shut up you're not actually
offended by that so stop it
we'll get to a point where people can
just express their opinion their point
of view
that's a it's a valid point of view in
fact
now i'm in favor of the stimulus as i've
said a million times because
just really on on principle more than
anything else
that the government has told people that
can't go to work and has shut down
entire industries and
and you know thousands of um of
businesses have gone over
under because of the government and so
they owe it
they owe it if they if if the government
has told you you can't go to work or if
they've destroyed
your business they owe you money
and so it's not an entitlement now
unlike student loan forgiveness which
was what he was first talking about
there now that is like an entitlement
an entitlement in the sense in in the
way that that word has been used
historically in this country
which is that when we talk about
entitlements usually we're talking about
people getting money that they're not
actually entitled to so
uh with a stimulus the the irony is that
that actually another in another sense
in a very literal sense that is an
entitlement because you are actually in
this case entitled to it so
that all gets very confusing but um as
far as the stimulus goes
this is the government's fault for
shutting down the economy
and they owe it so that's my take on it
however however it's
also true that six hundred dollars
or twelve hundred dollars or two
thousand dollars
that's not gonna solve anybody's problem
if
if you've been bankrupted
or your business has been destroyed by
the lockdowns
then six hundred dollars even two
thousand dollars
that's that is
that's not even a band-aid
so it is a question how how many people
in the country right now
are in a position because of the
lockdowns
where they're really hurting but what
all they need is twelve hundred and
twelve hundred bucks is gonna
is going to solve everything does anyone
fall into that category i think there
are a lot of people who
who've done okay through the lockdown
because their industry wasn't that
affected by it
that's the case by the way for the media
of which i'm i am in the media
um so there's a lot of people that are
that are doing fine or or they're in
another they're in another industry
where they could work from home that's a
lot of people
and they don't need the money they
shouldn't get anything a lot of them
will get money but they shouldn't
because they don't need it
if you haven't if you if you have been
working through the pandemic
and have not taken a big hit in your um
in your paycheck
that you should get zero dollars why
should you get anything
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated